[Musique]
les céréales est avec nous ses nattes ou
nat ou kate ici et qui m'a interpellé
dans une vidéo le 15 mars dernier giro
le jard un célèbre youtuber qu'on
embrasse a lancé un appel à la
mobilisation contre la famine en somalie
ils interpellaient en compte d'une
compagnie aérienne turque donc pour y
affronter un avion afin de pouvoir
envoyer de la nourriture
regardez ça ça c'est hyperimportant pong
vous voulez vraiment vous en parler soit
regarder 20 millions de personnes en
afrique de l'est qui n'ont plus d'eau
non plus de bétail n'ont plus de
nourriture et qui s'apprête à vivre la
pire famine les médias en parlent très
peu ça la réalité c'est qu'on peut se
mobiliser surtout avec les réseaux
sociaux on est tous sur les réseaux
sociaux et si on trouvait un avion etc
on remplissait de nourriture qu'on
remplissez d'eau et qu'on l'envoyait la
barre en somalie alors j'ai identifié
qu'il y avait une compagnie aérienne qui
jusqu'en somalie c'est karl heinz et si
vous êtes un influenceur ou si vous êtes
un journaliste c'est encore plus votre
responsabilité de faire passer le
message
on peut essayer d'aider
ça c'est une magnifique initiative
d'ailleurs de gironde on embrasse fort
et la compagnie aérienne a répondu
favorablement à cet appel et affrète
donc un vol cargo dans lequel de la
nourriture seront envoyés en somalie
une cagnotte alors été lancée sur
internet pour récolter de l'argent et
acheter de la nourriture et en trois
jours et après une énorme chaîne de
solidarité donc il ya eu plus de 70000
personnes qui ont participé et +21 mieux
oui à 200 mille dollars qui ont été
récoltés près de deux millions de
dollars c'est incroyable pour participer
à cette cagnotte donc vous allez sur le
lien qui s'affiche actuellement la à
l'écran est aussi sur notre compte
twitter ou la page facebook puisque natu
a également lancé un appel et m'a
directement interpellé et vue n'a tout
j'ai tout de suite répondu
pour nathan regarder la love a remis
force malien la cagnotte est déjà plus
de 1 million 500 mille dollars en moins
d'une semaine c'est un truc de dingue
aujourd'hui j'ai nomine 3 influenceurs
qui n'ont pas encore parlé de cette
cagnotte et qui vont pouvoir la propager
encore plus grâce à leur énorme force de
frappe cyril hanouna
je pense qu'avec l'impact énorme que
vous avez monsieur hanouna vous pouvez
encore rallié tellement de gens à cette
cause humanitaire et soit eu encore plus
fous pourquoi ne pas en parler ne serait
ce qu'une minute dans touche pas à mon
poste ce serait incroyable ce serait
génial ce serait grandiose
[Applaudissements]
cette saignée qu'est ce que c'est cette
recette c'est très important ce qui se
passe en ce moment c'est hyper important
et je vous le dis non vraiment près de 3
millions de personnes souffrent de la
voilà de faim en somalie on a besoin de
vous et je vais en fait de manière
globale c'est la pire crise humanitaire
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale il ya
20 millions de personnes qui souffrent
de famine et thomas voeckler sont en
parle et on wii et qu'on en parle aux
infos on n'a pas la solution c'est pas
trop sérieux et donc la concrètement il
se passe un truc de malade en moins
d'une semaine on a deux millions de
dollars et on a besoin de voler shihri
et ils ont besoin alors je vais nommer
trois personnes voilà bah moi aussi ce
soir je vais nommer booba voit la buba
obligatoires voilà mon booba il faut que
tu fasses quelque chose je vais nommer
mon pote également teddy riner voilà
jeudi à teddy riner voilà si peur aux
autres et je vais prendre un gars aussi
qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes voilà sur
twitter je vais nommer david guetta
voilà david guetta booba et teddy riner
les chéris allez-y en aboyant 12c les
trois personnes est la sienne et je sais
qu'elles vont relayer
love a remis forcément lien merci à tous
d'être là dedans